it's great to be joined today by Natasha
Shull who's a cultural anthropologist
and associate professor in New York
University's department of media culture
and communication also author of the
book addiction by design
Natasha it's so great to have you on I
read the book I guess at this point it's
been about six weeks or so and I found
so many aspects of it really really
interesting and I think to start would
be sort of the process that you went
through in the writing of this book
which if I recall correctly is over a
decade is it not definitely over a
decade because it began as an
undergraduate thesis in the 1990s I was
getting my undergraduate anthropology
degree and that was a time when many
anthropologists were turning their
lenses on themselves so to speak rather
than going to far-flung locales and I
being a downtown New Yorker who rarely
even went above 14th Street had found it
incredibly bizarre and exotic when I
went out to California for college and
stopped over in Las Vegas and that had
always stuck in my head so here I was as
a senior in anthropology and that
experience came back to me and I
proposed writing my senior thesis on
what was then going on and was known as
the Disney vacation of Las Vegas so you
saw all of these architectural forms and
volcanoes and spectacle so that's really
how it began was a study of the interior
design and the theme of Las Vegas and in
the book you interview everyone from the
designers of video slot machines to
individuals struggling with gambling
addiction to casino designers I mean
it'sit's unbelievably comprehensive and
I think to start with I'd like to talk a
little bit about casino design and the
psychology that goes into casino design
I think if you say this to a lot of
people they immediately think of some of
the talking points that are very common
there's no clocks on the wall oxygen is
pumped in and there's sort of a few you
know of these of these talking points
that you often hear but it's it's
unbelievably involved what goes into
in terms of how the individual patron or
gambler is going to sort of be
influenced by their environment can you
just get us into maybe what you consider
to be some of the most interesting
aspects of what goes into casino design
yeah I mean you do hear often about how
there's a sort of obvious ones that are
out there some of which are kind of
missed and some of which are absolutely
true yeah um no clocks on the wall so
you don't have a sense of time passing
and there's no windows that put natural
light into the casino so again you don't
really know how much time you've spent
there what I learned in interviewing the
casino interior designers decorators and
managers was about a whole other set
that we don't hear about it all which as
you say are really go down to a granular
level of environmental control sometimes
this is known in the industry as casino
atmospherics and everything from
manipulating the sounds decibel the the
light meter you know walking around and
sort of measuring what is the lighting
like and what is the sound like and how
does that correlate to the income that
these particular gaming areas are
bringing in to carpet design so a lot of
attention is given to how the carpets
flow and move one really interesting
example is that you try to never have a
right angle in a carpet because the
right angle what that does to somebody
is make them stop short and make a
decision where they have to decide will
I turn right into a gaming area or
continue straight in another direction
and the casino does not want you to be a
decision making rational actor they
don't they want to avoid that position
of being in a decision-making capacity
so they always try to curve the carpet
so that you're never in a moment of
rational decision-making left turn right
turn you just kind of move with the
carpet where the casino would ideally
like you to go and that's really how
this project evolved into one on slot
machines
you know in its phase one when it was
still about casino interior design
almost all of these design techniques
that I'm touching on ended up being in
the service of getting patrons over and
in front of slot machines and then
keeping them there so that always stuck
with me so that when I returned to this
project as a graduate student and then
after graduate school to write a book it
really at that point was all about the
slot machine as the main cash cow on the
floor and how all of these diverse
techniques are being used to get people
to play them longer faster and more and
the audience maybe I don't know if
surprised or even maybe in disbelief at
that granular level that you talk about
that that is used here in terms of
design I mean one of the other aspects
you talk about in the book is with
regards to sort of ceiling height and
density of sort of objects around you
that in order to create a welcoming
environment for someone to sit and play
for a while particularly with slot
machines you don't want a ceiling that's
too low but you don't want a ceiling
that's too high you don't want the
machines too far apart where people feel
sort of exposed and very visible but you
also don't want everything too close
together where people sort of feel it
may be more claustrophobic or something
like that
these every aspect of this is very
carefully tested isn't it absolutely and
what was really interesting for me is
that that wasn't just about getting you
know people to flow in certain ways
around the casino but once they are
sitting down at a slot machine how do
you keep them there and the interior
designers talked about creating these
private playing worlds where you can get
lost and absorbed and again lose track
of time and space in even a sense of who
you are in the world a sense of self and
the gamblers talked about this also they
talked about going into this kind of
zone and I found it so interesting how
the gamblers phenomenological experience
on the one hand of what it was like to
become lost in a machine was being
supported in all of these very tangible
architectural material decorative
ways by by the casinos and but what you
mentioned about the ceiling height is
very important so once you're sitting
down you want to reduce lines of sight
and long perspective points which again
might put you in the position of someone
who is aware of themselves as one unit
in a larger world you'd rather create a
sense that you're just kind of merging
with that world a more kind of baroque
Sensibility so you try to crowd objects
bring the ceiling height down and create
a sense of sort of clutter coziness
confusion you try to make it sort of
like a cave so that you'll see a lot of
casinos putting banks of slot machines
in corners or in cozy little nooks and
even if they don't have walls around
them you create a sense of walls by
bringing the ceiling down with like a
circle over it so it's almost like the
eye will extend the lines down to the
floor and you have a sense of what the
casino is called perceptual shelter in
which you can then get lost in these
devices in part two of the interview
we're going to delve more into some of
the research that you did with gamblers
let's talk now a little bit about why
casinos would have an interest in
designing casinos such that people are
moved towards sitting at electronic
gambling machines and this can include
slot machines this can also include
video poker and some other digital games
why is it that casinos have an interest
in encouraging these comfortable
situations for those particular games
versus hey let's get people sitting at
poker tables for example so poker tables
well poker tables have never there
that's an interesting case because it's
the one game where you don't play
against the house right huh that's
always been a sort of outlier game but
maybe like like a better example right
blackjack craps relax all of these kinds
of games
baccarat those used to be the real
moneymakers and they were thought is
that that's where you go if you're a
rear
that's the kind of central area of the
casino and you would sometimes find slot
machines around the periphery at the
edges they typically did not have any
seats in front of them and they were
thought of as being for the girlfriends
of the real gamblers and you see this
beginning to flip in the the late 70s
early 80s and by the 90s it really has
completely flipped and at that point the
real the golden geese the cash cows the
incredible revenue drivers of the casino
floor which are then given sort of
Geographic pride of place in the center
of the casino are the slot machines and
this has to do with the development of
micro processors and computer chip
technology as well as video technology
both of those technological innovations
allowed the game to have much more
flexibility in its design so that you
could really play with what's called the
reward schedule which could also be
called the the losing schedule it served
the pattern by which rewards are
dispensed or not can be far more finely
tuned and manipulated by by the house to
keep people there an extract revenue
from them and one of the most
interesting aspects of that natascha
that I found in the book that I think
our audience will find really really
interesting is in moving from a sort of
physical slot machine reels over to the
electronic slot machines there's been a
sort of distortion of the implicit odds
that a player might perceive as they're
playing and and the the sort of way that
I explain it would be if you've got a
three actually I don't even know it
would be called a three roll slot
machine is that the right term three
reel three reel slot machine that might
have you know twenty images on each reel
so to speak as a human when you see that
sort of rolling around you have some
intuition as to what your odds are of
hitting a jackpot the same thing on
every line or whatever that intuition
might be wrong
but at least you have some assessment of
that and when you map those digitally
all of a sudden the spaces between the
individual signs become slots or
possible landing zones I know that I'm
using the wrong language here but the
point is that that drastically skews the
odds not in the favor of the player and
the player may not even cognitively
realize that right there's all of these
interesting new layers of hidden
deception which just as an aside red
flag that they are all absolutely in
violation of existing consumer
protections but nobody's making any kind
of legal action against them because
there's just no no incentives in the
legal field to do that nobody
understands the computer technology etc
but you see this sort of sequential
layering of further levels of
obfuscation and deception and the one
that you're talking about would be when
mechanical real three mechanical reels
with 22 symbols each on them that used
to really limit the amount of a jackpot
you could give how often you could give
it and that's when you didn't really
want people hanging out for a long
period in front of the slot machines
once you started to be able to
manipulate that through what's called
the virtual real so you would still see
rolling in front of you these three
reels with 22 stops each and if you're
interacting with that over days and
weeks and sometimes even years for
regular gamblers you do get a kind of
intuitive sense even if you're not
conscious of it of what the odds are
because the odds are directly correlated
to the symbols that you are being shown
that are being presented to you on the
reels that link between perception what
you see and what the odds actually are
was completely severed by the
introduction of virtual reels because if
you imagine that inside the casino on
the chip is the whole other reel which
may have instead of 22 stops to reel a
hundred or more and on those reels you
can kind of wait
them so that the blank spots in between
symbols may be often right above and
below the winning symbols are going to
be keyed to be hit far more often than
the actual symbol so there's this whole
sort of invisible real that's spinning
inside the machine an easy way to think
about it we all know what loading the
dice is you actually physically take
some kind of metal and you you put it
you load the dice so that it's going to
end up on certain numbers rather than
others this is a digital way of loading
the device you're using an algorithm in
programming to to weight these blank
spots and really control the odds and
people are completely unaware of this so
they're still interacting with the same
three reels but those aren't really the
reels that are determining the outcomes
of the game let's pick it up there we've
been speaking with NYU professor Natasha
Schell about the book addiction by
design we'll continue our conversation
tomorrow we're continuing our
conversation with Natasha shawl who's a
cultural anthropologist and associate
professor in New York University's
department of media culture and
communication we've been talking about
the book addiction by design and we left
off talking a little bit about the ways
in which electronic slot machines can be
manipulated that mechanical slot
machines cannot now Natasha there's a
few other interesting ways that I think
are important to talk about about how
these electronic slot machines can
really distort the perception of the
gambler in terms of how they're
interacting with the machine one is what
I call near misses which is that
visually it can appear as though you
almost hit a jackpot but again because
we're talking about a digital real not a
mechanical machine a near-miss is
mathematically no different than being
way off from winning a jackpot and this
is very deceptive in terms of its
influence on the gambler isn't it
absolutely I mean if we're talking about
what we were just discussing these
virtual real and how it plays out on the
mechanical real
and it's using that mechanical real to
present the idea that you were very
close to winning when in fact you were
no closer to winning than if you had
been far away from that symbol so again
it's really manipulating the perception
of the user and that that really does
change user behavior so this near miss
effect carries over to things that even
came after the virtual real the virtual
real remember is still using three
actual mechanical reals since then you
know you still find those and they're
still popular and money drivers on the
casino floor but what's really risen to
the very top in terms of value to the
casino how much profit they reap are
what are called multi-line video slot
machines and you'll sometimes go into a
casino and you'll you'll look at these
machines you won't even recognize what's
going on typically it's a video screen
with a whole grid of many symbols that
are all moving as if they were reels
there could be ten reels with five lines
across and if you stand behind someone's
playing one of these you'll see that
they're not just betting two lineup
symbols straight across horizontally on
one line
there are many lines across there are
also diagonals
there are also zigzags and all sorts of
ways and sometimes there's just what's
called scatter which has no rationale at
all you can't really link anything up so
what people are doing is for the first
time on slot machines you're dividing up
your bet almost as if you're
diversifying your portfolio by investing
in many different machines at once it's
sort of like playing you know see if you
have a 300 line machine playing 300 slot
machines at once and you're betting
maybe a penny on each line so say you
know you're betting three dollars you're
going to probably win back on some of
those and when you do you're going to
hear ding ding ding ding it's going to
light up flash and you're going to hear
music ah you may win back three cents
out of your dollar
you're $3 you may win back 50 cents
that's a net loss in fact that the major
you've lost a major portion of your bet
but you're getting all the same
audiovisual reinforcement and brain
studies have shown when they hook people
up to scanners and other kinds of brain
metrics of measuring apparatus is that
your brain interprets this as an actual
win there's there's no distinction made
as you're rapidly cycling through these
things and for the casinos it ends up
being a way to extract money over time
while the player doesn't realize it's
happening they often refer to this as
giving the players a smoother ride so
it's like cushioning the effect it's
really interesting to me because it
seems to be against the whole sense of
gambling which is about volatility and
risk and suspense and sort of the thrill
of maybe losing maybe winning and this
is actually just sort of the same
reinforcement it lulls you into a kind
of trance
and whether you're winning whether
you're losing just ding ding dinging and
then it goes on and your eyes kind of
glaze over one designer told me that
these algorithms are like he said we
want to design a mathematical gaming
algorithm that's like reclining on a
comfortable couch and that was really
interesting to me when we talk about
gambling addiction as a problem and look
at some of the statements or assertions
that are made by the casino industry you
often hear for example you know only 1%
of the population really is susceptible
to or is you know has gambling addiction
and every time I read that I think to
myself right but a lot of those people
never go to casinos a lot of the 99%
that don't have this issue or not in
casinos and it's always seem more
relevant to me what percentage of the
people that gamble have a predisposition
or gambling addiction and and I'm
wondering whether we even have that data
right and so you know and also you have
to take out those under 21 etcetera so
if you if you look at a tennis
hard to find this data reliably in any
general sense you can find studies that
have done it that way in certain
locations etc but really on what you
want to look at is the percentage of the
adult gambling population that is and
even within that the percentage of the
adults gambling population that plays on
machines what percentage of them are
addicted I believe somewhere out there
is a statistic that the gaming industry
themselves came up with showing
something like 12% but their studies
shown suggesting that it's around 20%
and this really is in line with a lot of
other research showing that there's
something about the digital the solitude
the speed and the continuity of this
particular gaming format that makes it
uniquely addicting you know we always
like to talk about or I should say that
the gambling industry likes to talk
about genetic propensity to gamble as if
you know 1% of the population is born
attic and we need to worry about them
and how to mitigate their experience but
the rest of us can gamble with immunity
and really I think any addiction
researcher knows that to have an
addiction you can't just have a
predisposition you need an interaction
between a subject and an object and if
you look at the kind of interaction you
have with these slot machines it's far
more potent than say blackjack where
you've got to wait for your turn to come
again or horse racing where you've got
to wait for the race to finish there's a
term in addiction research called event
frequency and if you look at the event
frequency which literally means how many
times is happening you know within a
minute within an hour it's really off
the charts with these slot machines you
can play 1,200 hands an hour on those
new video slot machines that I was
telling you about and there's really
very little pause to self stop
to take to take stock of where you're at
to make a decision to keep playing or
not and that's why I feel that all of
this discourse around responsibility
it's kind of a moot point because it's
really difficult to have a responsible
consumer when the thing that they are
interacting with chips away at their
very capacity for responsibility through
this tight interaction solitude
continuity you can just keep going
there's never any moment to stop and the
sheer speed or event frequency and the
the gambling industry the casino
industry has sort of taken advantage of
the medicalization of gambling addiction
to sort of get get out from under at
least some of the responsibilities that
could be attributed to the mechanisms
and the machines right I mean it's very
easy to say hey listen we're talking
about a medical problem here we're just
an entertainment place most people don't
have this medical problem and thus we
don't really have to worry or be
scrutinized for how the machines work
but as you're talking about that's not
true because it ignores that a
predisposition does not necessarily mean
that you are going to start having a
problem it depends on the environment
and the machines and so many other
things exactly of course it's the case
that some people come in the world more
likely or more liable to become addicted
to things that present themselves along
the way but I always like to say that by
the same token certain objects and
substances come into this world far more
liable to addicts have the story when
you're talking about an addiction as an
interaction that builds between an
individual and an object or a substance
half the story lies with that object or
substance and that's really what my work
delves into I mean it's absolutely the
case that the industry prefers to look
only at the person side focusing not
just on genetics but on personal
biography and other kind of factors that
all point back to the individual because
that ends up deflecting attention away
from the products and onto the person
and you see this playing out
other domains as well it's very similar
to the guns don't kill people people
kill people
alcoholics don't come in bottles they
come in people I mean there's many
industries where you can find this kind
of rhetoric and the gambling industry is
no exception
where they are an exception is that they
have learned from the failures of say
tobacco to ignore at their own peril the
fact that this is that this addiction is
real and you can even find transcript of
industry summit online where they get
together and they decide you know in Las
Vegas we need to really craft the
rhetoric here we don't want to be like
those tobacco guys all raising our hands
later to be proven wrong and guilty and
lying saying you know addiction doesn't
exist there's nothing addictive in these
we want to be the guys who capture the
definition of what the addiction is and
how it's happening and by doing that
they throw money at genetic research etc
and they've even there's the gambling
industry themselves the American gaming
industry is the largest funder of
research around gambling addiction and
unsurprisingly despite claims to having
a you know a peer-review system etc that
would weed out by it unsurprisingly most
of it goes toward research which focuses
on the person part and you even see the
leaders of this National Center for
Responsible gaming that funds all this
research you see things on the homepage
like quote you know the slot machine
can't addictive it's just an object we
need to help the people so there's a
political discourse there's a PR
campaign behind this well the book is
absolutely fascinating we've been
speaking about Natasha Scholes book
addiction by design we could talk for
many more hours about it but
unfortunately that's all the time we
have but I highly recommend you check
out the book Natasha thanks so much for
talking to us about this and cribbing me
on David